Keira Knightley what will be worse for
you having to sing in front of a large
audience or do your sex faces right now
I'm gonna ask you to do them now and so
please we're just asking the
conceptually which would be worse cuz
dangerous dangers method you do a lot of
sex places I had to do a lot of sex
faces I had to do a lot of like weird
sex faces oh no that's not a weird sex
face but you know shoot she is she's a
bit of a weird character that's nerdy no
it was directed by
like a movie
uh yeah I had to go on skype with David
Cronenberg so that he could see what my
planned weird sex faces were that's no
it's also on every level because I'd
never met him before
so like to say hello nice to meet you
and then all of a sudden have to go so
hey what are your sex faces which I'd
been practicing in the mirror just
before which is a wait a thing to do and
I went on and I got in the mint because
they were meant to be like horrible sex
faces so so they were horrible but Skype
throws like meeting with this big
director who I think is amazing was
something you just this kind of great
but you do think that I don't worry
about sex no no no no care you know I'm
not saying that you mean like bad sex
faces six phases that's two very
differently yeah you know a bad sex face
is just
but was it that so uncomfortable known
with with directors Joe right in
Atonement so again it's making sweet
love
yeah he's directing you but he's
shouting instructions yeah so it's like
it I don't know there's a scene we're
having sex up against the books
bookshelf as you do and it's with the
lovely James McAvoy he's a friend he's
really lovely and it's always awkward
cuz he's friend and that's awkward and
we're in the middle of it and suddenly
this voice just goes Keira wank him off
okay
what they don't know when they're
sitting there watching the dead like
look at that you know it's like 15 guys
standing around as a gallon sandwich
like faster
it's not a tough for us to cuz you're
coming to room you go okay so where can
I touch you okay where can I not touch
you okay um I want to apologize now for
getting excited oh I want to apologize
now for not getting excited yeah you
don't know you know actions could be
upset
either way sorry oh I'm not your type
huh
and I will strike down upon thee with
great vengeance and furious anger those
who attempt to poison and destroy my
brothers and you will I don't have any
money but when I do him